marking 45 years in las vegas station
casinos holding a really special
anniversary celebration tonight
with fireworks and music and a whole lot
of fun sasha loftus joining us live from
palace station with more
on the big event tonight in the history
of these local casinos we've all come to
know
brian it was quite the show out here
tonight as fireworks
lit up the night sky station casinos
marking nearly half
a century serving southern nevada nevada
rather from right here where it all
started
celebrating 45 years serving las vegas
it's our birthday you guys it's our
birthday station casinos held a special
event thursday night
as it boasts decades of business that
all started here
at palace station it broke ground in
1976
and was simply dubbed the casino then
became bingo palace
and eventually adopted the name we all
know today
when you come here you really do feel
like you're at home joe yalda
who works as vice president of guest
experience at red rock
says station's founder frank fertitta jr
hope to cater to
and represent the local las vegas
community
when you come to a city like las vegas
and you end up moving here
you're almost there's this like magnetic
pull to our properties because
it has such a community outreach and
it's not just here for the natives
stations also touts an essence of family
just ask employees and sisters latoya
grant and crystal thomas
they absolutely care about us as an
individual we're not just numbers
and though this once small company has
grown into a city staple
those here hope this connection to their
roots
will help them mark many more years to
come we're excited to just enjoy this
time right now with stations
station casinos has two more fireworks
celebrations planned for
sunday this july fourth holiday one is
at red rock and one is at green valley
ranch resort we have more information
on those link to our website eight
newsnow dot com
reporting live tonight sasha loftis 8
news now